Hello everybody, Dr. Cutters, section 5 of Beating Credit Climb.
I don't want to try to keep these videos a little shorter.
There's a lot of information, so you've got to read the book too.
So understand, your download of this whole book and this whole program
actually contains a lot more than what is actually in that printed book.
So if you purchase the book on Amazon, just beware.
I've added a lot of information to your download pieces.
So there's just more information.
I know I try to add it.
So we're a practice, we're constantly updating, we're constantly improving.
That's just us.
So please be aware of that.
Understanding barriers.
We talked about this last section.
The blood brain barrier is so important.
And break down to that barrier causes all sorts of things.
But the main thing that causes this brain inflammation.
I love this kind of thing.
What doctors are really thinking?
It's chronic fatigue syndrome.
Beating, I have no freaking idea what you got.
Well, that's unfortunately most doctors situation.
We just don't always want to admit that.
There's always a reason why.
I mean, that is our motto.
Figure out why.
You don't just have arthritis.
There's a reason why you have arthritis.
Could it be live?
Yes, it could be.
Find a doctor that can figure that out.
Could it be heavy metal toxicity?
Yeah, it could be.
Maybe it isn't live.
It's something else.
There's all sorts of possible reasons.
You got to figure that out.
That's a really important thing.
So when you have this activated microglial cell system in the brain,
you have an op-regulation of what's called your TH-17 response.
And possibly it gets worse if you have an op-regulated TH-1 response to the brain.
It's very destructive.
It's a form of a lot of symptoms of ADD-80 HD.
There's many forms of ADHD that we list in our brain book and how we treat brain issues.
Person can have a lot of anxiety.
It can be in a hypersympathetic state.
That's very common.
And it could be what's called limbic.
So there is a limbic state.
They have an inability of the frontal lobe to down-regulate some deeper brain centers.
So your frontal lobe's purpose is really to be the executive of the brain.
It gives you your reasoning power.
It gives it fires impulses to other brain centers.
And most of those impulses basically turn off other brain centers.
So they are...
Think of your frontal lobe as the parent of the brain and the deeper brain centers as the naughty teenager.
So when your parent can't...
can't parent the naughty teenagers when it's turned off, then we have a problem.
And then you start acting out in a very limbic manner.
So we see that very common with Lyme disease.
Symptoms with Lyme disease.
Anything from meningitis type symptoms that's acute inflammation of the brain.
And to painful rediculitis that means shooting pain in different parts, inflammation of nerves.
I'm not going to read all these.
You can look at those.
They're listed in the book.
I had a patient contact me a few weeks ago saying that he had every symptom that I had listed in the book, every single symptom.
We hear that a lot.
It's just a very, very debilitating disorder.
You know when you got that kind of symptoms, you're already in phase three.
Most people that contact us are in phase three because otherwise they wouldn't be contacting us.
So remember those phases.
And we're going to be digoted to those more on our next presentation.
So again, if you have any questions, feel free to contact us.
And I'll see you at the next section.